[Music]
[Applause]
season openers for the NBA 76ers Celtics
Lakers and the Warriors that'll be on
TNT a double header and that means
Charles Barkley has to work tonight he
decided a new con let me get the
official press release Charles Barkley
has agreed to a 10-year deal with TNT
expected to be well into nine figures
the post has learned the New York Post
and uh the exact amount Barclay will
make is not yet known if he fulfills the
entire contract could be well in excess
of 100 million dollars could approach
200 million dollars
Charles Barkley joined us on the program
drinks are on you Charles
uh drinks are definitely on Chuck man I
just want to thank my TNT family uh man
I've got a great company I work for so
I'm excited to be back with TNT and uh
looking forward to the future how did
the uh live tour negotiations affect or
did they affect your contract with TNT
zero uh
zero percent you know TNT asked me like
uh they said we need something from you
would you give us something
and I said what do you want they're like
we need you to stay longer we can't lose
you and be it on the NBA
so that's how the negotiations started
and went I says well
I don't want to work till the day I drop
dead they're like well we need you to
stay at least three more years because
we got the uh
they're going to bid on the NBA I mean
actually I think they're probably going
to start bidding on the NBA really soon
they said we can't let you leave in
three years and be it on the NBA so they
asked me would I signed for a couple
more years
and I said well you guys been great to
me
I'll stay on a couple more years and uh
I mean there's probably zero chance I'm
gonna stay for the entire 10 years Dan
to be honest with you but they've been
great to me and I wanted to do something
for them and they did me a favor all
right how does your agent approach
negotiations can you factor in what Tony
Romo makes or Troy Aikman makes or the
analyst in different sports uh what Tom
Brady is going to make from Fox
because you're extremely valuable and
I've said you're probably the most
valuable member of the media right now
so how do you go in and negotiate
well then number one you said that
before and I want to thank you for the
kind words uh first of all I didn't uh
my agent who I love Mark Harmon he's
done a fantastic job had nothing to do
with this I met with Turner personally
because dude I'm not worried about money
at this stage of my life listen if I
don't have enough about money by now I'm
a big idiot I mean I played 16 now I
mean seriously Dan I played 16 years in
the NBA and this is my 22nd year
starting night on turn if I don't have
enough money by now
I'm just an idiot well you're not a very
good Gambler though so I gotta factor in
you know well I I factor when I read it
um when I read negotiate my deals and do
commercials I factor in gambling losses
that's your gambling lost money when you
do your Subway commercials
uh Subway Capital One Dick's Sporting
Good hey and I want to thank the Broncos
and uh and the charges for the worst
boring football game in the history of
civilization last night
no no no that's that was last third the
last two Thursdays are worse than what
we had last night uh uh you're right
what was the game that was worse than
last night uh yeah the Bears and the
commanders that was that that was the
worst that was the worst
worst my ever seen until last night
but to tell you how uh how crazy this
thing is last week I had the Bears and
last night I had the Broncos and the
only reason I would watch two games that
bad is I bet on them yes but don't I'm
damn I'm not joking last Thursday
when they were like at the three yard
line all they need is a touchdown that
was the worst game I'd ever seen until
last night but the only good thing but
the only good thing about last
I had the Broncos plus four okay all
right congratulations
um thank you yeah basketball tonight I'm
more interested in the ring ceremony for
the Golden State Warriors
um if you're how does Jordan pool it
feels like the pressure's on Jordan
Poole to handle all of this not Draymond
Green
does that sound right
wow that's the answer I don't think
there's anything they can do I think
this family is fractured I don't think
you can put it back together
uh Draymond was 100 wrong
and he's apologized so we just keep it
moving but he was wrong but I don't
think you can put this thing back
together
you know like Dan if if you punch like
in a family if you just punch one of
your family members yeah y'all probably
don't get past it but your relationship
will never be the same did you punch a
teammate in practice or get punched
I got to fighting and practice one time
with Oliver Miller
and I apologize but it was more of a
wrestling contest I didn't just sucker
punch him
I think obviously if you suck a punch
somebody that's a totally different
animal if two guys I know you're getting
ready to fight and I think Oliver was
wrong and I think I was probably wrong
for for coming at him but I remember we
had went away to training camp to get
ready to go to the finals
and Oliver was screwing around and I
said yo man I'm going to the finals for
the first time in my career I don't need
you out here jacking around
I said I've never been to the founders
before and you're out here jacking
around and he said something to me
sarcastic and I said hey if you keep it
up I'm gonna kick your ass and he says
well kick my ass
and I and I now so then when you tell
somebody
you're gonna fight them that's totally
different
than just walking up on him and sucker
punching them
so like I say I don't know if this
relationship can be
repaired and I obviously are going to be
professional
but I don't think their relationship can
ever be the same again and Jordan pool
is more valuable to this team as they
move forward and you know like Draymond
Green is is a good player for that team
but it's but at some point you have to
say we got a new wave of younger players
we want to keep Steph and clay
you know are you going to bring back you
know Draymond is going to exercise his
option I think for one more year but if
you're Golden State at what point do you
move on from him
that's a great question amen draymond's
a good dude he made a mistake
the problem is he's going to be on this
team proud of the next couple of years
including the Warriors have moved on
and I'll tell you something man
if their young kids can play uh I'm a
big kuminga fan
I don't know about wife because I
haven't seen him play but with Moody
pool if kamaga and Wiseman can play this
team could win the championship they're
going to be in contention the next five
years at least you know Bob Myers has
he's probably passed RC Beaufort as the
best GM uh and I forget my man Oklahoma
City Sam president does a fabulous job
also with RC Buford was always uh in my
opinion the best GM in the NBA finding
Ginobili and Parker and Kawhi Leonard
and guys like that but what Bob Myers
did out here in San uh in San Francisco
getting Wiseman I mean obviously got a
great break getting a draft pick that
high but him and kamanga man but like
don't forget Moody and pool were low
draft picks yeah so this team could be
scary and Trayvon has to accept that
I mean he's he's been a heck of a player
he's a great role player
he's probably gonna be here two more
years and they're gonna move on but
that's the way Sports work yeah you know
he's been very well compensated for what
he's accomplished but you can't get mad
when teams want to move on from you Dan
you get paid for what you do not what
you used to do
he's the Hall of Famer Inside the NBA
analyst Charles Barkley the opening
night on TNT Celtics and the Sixers
followed by the Lakers and the Warriors
the over under if I said it at 65 and a
half games for Anthony Davis this year
are you going to over or under under
you know he's the key to the Lakers
he's a terrific Talent
I can actually skip tonight and put the
exact same thing I said on last year has
nothing to do with LeBron no no
seriously has nothing to do with LeBron
or Westbrook or any of those other guys
unless Anthony Davis is a top five
player the Lakers are going to be
mediocre it's the 100 hey LeBron's he's
on the Mount Rushmore one of my favorite
people in NBA history
I got him you know right up there with
Kobe LeBron magic bird Bill Russell and
Wilton those guys he's amazing he's
amazing man but he's 40 years old it's
100 gonna be on Anthony Davis if he's a
top five player
they could do some damage if he's not a
top five player the Lakers are going to
stink I said the exact same thing last
year LeBron put out that tweet time but
I want you to keep that same energy you
had over the night and I'm gonna have
that same energy open tonight if the
Lakers if Anthony Davis is not a top
five player the Lakers are going to be
mediocre at best how do you tell a
teammate who's not a good shooter to
stop shooting because because Russell
Westbrook has said publicly hey I'm a
good shooter and he's not he's a good
player or he can be a good player he's
not a good Shooters how do you how do
you do that if you have a teammate who's
is a gunner
Gunner is such a strong word Dan
um you know I'm never going to say
anything bad about Russell Westbrook
because man I admire the hell out that
dude because you know fans always talk
about
all I want for my players to give me one
percent effort Russell Westbrook is the
hardest player I've ever seen play in
the NBA
does he have flaws in this game 100
percent
but there's two story lines that we're
going to be watching in the NBA you know
the Lakers and the Brooklyn Nets
their must-watch television
we have no idea when uh when uh Russ is
going to punch Patrick Beverly
that's like we're gonna have to watch
because you know that little thing the
other day when he's trying to call him
in the Huddle yeah and Russell look like
no hell no I'm not going in the Huddle
that's real I I admire Russell Westbrook
for not doing funny stuff
in this situation in Brooklyn
man we got they could win the
championship or or they could get speed
nasified by Sunday I mean
dude we got zero idea but that's what
then you got the situation in Philly
well James Harden you know everybody is
asking me is James Harden cook I said I
don't know uh but he had the entire
summer the rehab his hamstring
but it's gonna be fun watching saying
because I can say I was like I don't
know if he's cooked or not but like I
say you got to watch Philly
you got to watch Brooklyn
and you got to watch it and you actually
got to watch what's happening out here
in San Francisco because
if they don't get off to a good start
they gonna have to do something about
the Draymond situation like you know
there and everybody knows this in sports
winning is the best deodorant
and if the Warriors don't get off to a
good start
because man everybody knows what's
happening you know we all talk we all
watch TV in the morning we all watch the
internet
if they don't get off to a good start it
like it could be serious issues here in
San Francisco so there's some great
story lines out here
and I can't wait to get started tonight
okay you're signing this new contract 10
years who knows if it's 100 million or
200 million are you going to treat
yourself to anything
Dan I've been buying whatever the hell I
lost since 1984. okay what's the worst
purchase you ever made
the worst that's a great question Dan
um
I bought a Porsche one time
and the one thing about Porsche first of
all it's an amazing car but they go too
fast
um and by the way it's Porsche
Dan they're not gonna correct me if I
walked
up they're gonna say which one you want
okay why was it a bad bad purchase
they go too fast you think you're going
like 60 70 and you're going like 110
and I'll tell you I was driving down the
Schuylkill in Philadelphia one night
it was raining and I was going about 117
miles an hour
I had a 944 Turbo
and I lost control of my car
and I closed my eyes and said in
hydroplane
and and I just closed my eyes and I said
well this is the end
and it's spent around like three or four
times
I took it back to the dealership the
next day
and I and then from that day forward
I've never driven a car I'm only driving
because SUVs only go so fast
that that night I've never drive
seriously I've never bought a car
since that night I said I'm never dry
because they're amazing cars but certain
cars make you go fast
and I'm like no I don't want to die I
don't wanna because Drive is fast is
just stupid I mean just because the car
goes 100 miles an hour that don't mean
you should be driving 100 miles an hour
so from that from that point on I've
never driven anything but a truck
have fun tonight play nice
I'm gonna play nice dude
Jack might not play nice
say what now Shaq might not play nice
oh man listen I you know what I haven't
seen the big fella talk to the big fella
since the season ended I can't wait to
see him tonight I'm gonna give him a big
hug and I can't I've seen Ernie I've
seen I've talked to Ernie I've talked to
Kenny but Shaq is always doing something
I can't wait to see the big fella now
I'm gonna give him a big hug great to
talk to you congrats on the deal and
thanks for joining us hey guys thanks
for Dan you make me get up and down
early in the damn morning man I'm going
back to bed thank you bud that's Charles
Barkley appreciate you guys you're
welcome they got a double header tonight
76ers Celtics at 7 30 Lakers Warriors at
10 Eastern